Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck are
better than ever basking in that
newlywed glow that JLo glow and now a
source tells ET there's zero drama in
fact they're thriving as Mr and Mrs it's
really quite an experience the couple
tied the knot over the summer nearly two
decades after calling off their first
engagement in 2004. it was my first kind
of heartbreak we were about to get
married it didn't work out and it was
just a bad heartbreak it was like
a tough one for me now ET Source says
that they love married life and feel
like they are true soul mates quote
everything is even better than the first
time they dated we're super happy what
can I tell you we're just having a good
time the source ads Jen is so content
with being a wife and being married Ben
makes her feel so loved and there's zero
drama things are better than ever and
they're so happy
the lovebirds made their first public
appearance as a married couple last week
at the Ralph Lauren runway show in Los
Angeles but according to E.T Source
their favorite thing to do these days is
kind of the opposite they love to watch
movies and TV together at home they love
to just have down time where they lounge
around me too benifer me too and when it
comes to their careers
ET Source says they talk a lot listen to
each other and give advice adding that
while they both have so much happening
in their careers it's not competitive
quote Jen gets to be herself and not
apologize for her success Ben has his
own career and it's great it works well
I feel like myself again and when it
comes to their blended family
ET Source says the transition has been
seamless quote Ben is so good with her
kids and she is great with his Jen
shares 14 year old twins Max and Emmy
with her ex Marc Anthony while Ben
shares 16 year old Violet 13 year old
Seraphina and 10 year old Samuel with
his ex Jennifer Garner quote Ben has
always been an awesome dad and that's
one of the reasons Jen loves him he's
just a solid and good man the kids feel
very close to him go to him for advice
and love him it's great the kids all
like each other too which helps a lot
[Music]
thank you